winter biomes Disney crossovers new
vehicles under new war rages on let's
talk about fortnight season 7 hello and
welcome to Playstation grenade it's my
favorite time of the fortnight cycle the
height week before the new season begins
piecing together the in-game hints and
subtle changes adding the files found by
leakers and interpreting the tweets sent
out by epic developers can we predict
season 7 content last season we did
pretty damn well predicting cowboy skins
zombies a castle the start of the war
between the food companies pets bunkers
opening up in wailing woods and even the
llama headed character so let's try it
all over again for season 7 you ready
let's do this
[Music]
we usually start with the story running
through the loading screens but season 6
was different from the usual format the
Halloween theme basically showed us new
skins in a variety of spooky fairytale
setups as the weeks passed the real
event began when Kevin became powerful
enough to summon the undead hogs once we
defeated all those busks we were given
tranquility and even had a rave in the
final week did I miss anything
hang on what the frig magnet is that oh
yeah aim box in week 8 he landed
complete with parachute and used his
heads-up display to look around but hold
on there cowboy
look at the map it's our first hint
toward season 7 content the map is
flipped as we are on the reverse to it
but that area there is flush factory and
look south of that something is
approaching this is when jumping in game
can help us identify more the first
thing to note is the parachute is truly
here but I want to come back to that if
I may and break down that logo very soon
first we need to find out what
unidentified object is out in the sea
at first I thought it was spawn island
but then we all looked a little closer
and saw the cloud of snow growing in the
distance this coupled with the fact that
aimbot has frozen coverings on his hands
and feet got me thinking everyone pretty
much believes the snow biome will be
added for season 7 after all they
attempted to put it in last year
but they couldn't get the world to
operate how they wanted but in PvP in
save the world
we had entire areas dedicated to frozen
farms and snow-covered rolling hills
we even had a troll frozen under water
to add to all this leakers have found
footsteps sound effects in the snow from
the latest Battle Royale update so we're
pretty certain we are getting snow but
whereabouts will it hit the islands some
people believe the entire map will be
covered but I don't think so I think
we'll get to by on a small portion using
the direction of the snowstorm it's
likely the lower corner of the map will
be covered could that snow cloud be an
iceberg time will tell I suppose snobby
Shores could become snowy Shores or
maybe flush factory could even become
Santa's little workshop no that's up to
this remember a few seasons back when
Valkyrie was introduced sitting on a
throne that completely gave away the
inclusion of a castle in season six
which appeared next to Haunted Hills in
the same way the new Deep Freeze bundle
has confirmed ice mountains I visited
all the mountain ranges attempting to
find this exact spot in the picture the
closest was actually picked mountai main
pencil Mountain that was a Freudian slur
yeah but there are mountains everywhere
which one do you think will change my
money is on the one above yonder yard
anyway let's move on from snow there's
so much more to get through than that
back over to the parachute aimbots left
behind at flush factory let's break down
the logo which is a dawned upon it this
symbol what do you see when you look at
it well it's jam-packed with references
first the rhombus shapes around the edge
hang on
is that a rhombus or a trapezoid someone
help me
does anybody know they're two 2d shapes
anyway those shapes replicate the
shutters of a camera this is used in
movies and TV to suggest someone is
watching it's part of the Big Brother
effect heck there's even a TV show
called Big Brother which is all about
voyeuristic tendencies and controlling
another person's environment anyone who
wants to know more about this phenomenon
a great place to start is the movie in
1984 and it's also happening in real
life in the EU right now look up article
13 if I suddenly vanish overnight I know
what you're thinking
get to the point Adam well the symbol
inside is the globe showing
that we are indeed being watched and to
compound this the inclusion of ice
embolize ease deep space putting all
three elements together we can surmise
that we are being watched by an
intergalactic satellite hmm very
interesting
also note that aimbot arrived via
parachute instead of a glider or
umbrella like we're used to this links
to space travel too with the preferred
method to bring shuttles back to earth
cradled by a parachute and the typical
colors used for these parachutes red and
white take Apollo 13 for instance
alright so there was a great deal of
information to take in there but the
main theme I want to take from all of
this is that we're being watched look at
the loading screens featuring aimbot
he's watching others in all of them
first he lands and uses his scouting
advanced technology to survey the area
next he's watching the aftermath of
Kevin the cube at the old loot lake and
finally he's at the end of season disco
lurking in wait ready for the call to
action I began looking into space robots
and one series of mechs linked to this
theory perfectly have you seen the movie
Elysium
it's a Matt Damon film in which
inhabitants of Earth are left to suffer
whilst the upper classes live on a Space
Station kind of like a satellite
orbiting the Earth these people are
protected by a police force of robots
these buggers are combat robots great
with a weapon in hand but share the same
physical structure of a man in the film
these robots can be sent down to earth
below to keep the peace or take down
powerful rebel causes in the story
Elysium is borrowed from the robots from
the satellite come down to earth to take
any technology they deem worthy kind of
like those portals and perma rifts
[Music]
segue hey speaking of those portals
we've all had fun walking around the
woods while those leakers have found
files which suggests there's more to
permits as I'm traveling a few hundred
metres this photo from super star beta
nice name dude could be a clickbait
Photoshop stitch or it could show us
that perma roofs can take us to another
area completely and maybe another
dimension maybe alternative realities we
know it's possible in this game world
thanks to the butterfly event by the way
if you want to watch all the live events
back-to-back I have video for your
troubles this image also suggests
another castle coming to Battle Royale
further leagues from a chap called fort
Torre back this up with assets that do
look legitimate another castle in
fortnight I suppose that snow cloud
could be an iceberg with a castle on top
which smashes into the lower portion of
the map hmm okay that sounds far-fetched
but I like it
in fact when NASA tweeted about a
perfectly flat piece of iceberg just
doing its thing and floating around
fortnight actually tweeted back and
asked if it was Kevin food-for-thought
indeed oh another segue food food let's
mix things up and revisit our prediction
from last season we prophesized the
inclusion of a food fight due to the
sudden change at somato temple and the
inclusion of this image depicting a derp
burger employee joining the pizza pit
site well not only were we right
congratulations if you predicted that -
this story doesn't look like ending
anytime soon over season six the dirt
vogel restaurant officially went out of
business and in a last-gasp attempt to
stay in business they took their grub on
the road but in their way stood the
pizza pit crew who also lost their home
and now take to the streets the two
companies have been fighting all season
with their trucks moving around the map
as I'm writing this they are currently
at the drive-in cinema of risky reels
but where the heck will they go next
maybe to the temple may be lonely Lodge
or maybe to another spot we suggested
last season wailing woods
[Music]
do you remember the theory we looked
into last season about a character who
had been waiting to join the fight he
was a chicken enthusiast who left food
around the map most noticeably at slowly
Lodge during season six on the day of
Thanksgiving he appeared in the game the
tender defender
if leaks have to be trusted he will join
the food fight with his own company and
those two-way battles will become a
3-way sausage fest
they don't make sausages do that that
Joe could have been good but the sausage
restaurant is in save the world job it
I'll try again next season the food
factory also included an ever growing
theme park to be added to the map it
looks impossible a few seasons back but
look how far we've come a food fight
limited time game-mode and even the
eventual inclusion of that chicken shop
owner by the way how good is this glider
best waste of money
ever to once again set the foundations
of this theory in proven fact recently
those lovely leek has found a hamburger
file which made a strange sound
when processed using a spectrogram the
image found on aimbots armor is
uncovered could both of these theories
line up let's change focus again
recently epic employees have tweeted
about looking into new ways to travel
and Traverse around the map but they
always said in Battle Royale rather than
in fortnight could this suggests that
the hopper bought from save the world
could be coming over to Battle Royale
those things are so damn cool and if you
love back to the future you will love
these hoverboards of course with a new
snow biome likely we could see snow
themed traversal instead such as a
snowboard maybe I'm calling it now
skiing minigame maybe not so I'm sure by
now you've seen the wreck-it ralph
Easter Egg in risky reels well this
actually links into so much more
fortnight history so let's uncover it
back in season four there was a skin
themed around candy Zoe she had a glider
and a pickaxe so straight out of a movie
and you guessed it it was record Ralph
she uses the identical color scheme to
candlehead back in present day the free
emote hot Mirat is straight from
wreck-it Ralph - and the tiny fortnight
cameo where Ralph is trying to do the
fortnight him
he's on screen for like two seconds at
most it looks like Disney and fortnight
have been working towards this crossover
for a while remember--the annals yeah
he's a Disney property so the
relationship is already in place and
there's more if you didn't know I used
to be a teacher which included art
fundamentals well I couldn't help but
notice all the pets included in season
six aren't drawn in the typical
fortnight style they instead used Disney
design techniques hence why they look so
familiar instantly it's basically a
timeless drawing style when we put all
these elements together we can safely
say many Disney crossovers are plunked a
spotlight continues to welcome new
gamers daily I think there's 200 million
offers in our think back to fan offs
how easy would it be to reskin him as a
Ralph in fact what about a candy biome
like in sugar rush I'm getting
sidetracked and can't hunt oh let's
finish with a few smaller indicators we
should watch out for over the season did
you notice the awesome buff to the
pickaxe five hits and you're always gone
this is highly likely test work for
upcoming melee weapons which are hella
fun to use in PvE save the world I don't
have anything else to base that on so
I'm not going to dwell let's move on but
speaking of save the world mechanics new
characters have been added to the game
mode which aren't playable at the moment
but I can definitely see these
transitioning into battle royale only
for us save the world oh geez also
remember twitch prime skins they were so
good and helped streamers no end looking
at the figures behind twitch subscribers
it's highly likely twitch pac---- 3 you
will return in season 7 most people's
subscriptions lapse in January or
February so maybe just maybe at the
moment another twitch prime incentive
will appear in the first half of 2019
writer rattled on enough but I want your
help with something
what on earth are the enforcers here for
what do they do in this story
after the visitor crash-landed in season
4 and this season's aimbots having an
obvious upcoming role in BOTS night
there's a huge question about what the
heck the enforcers were here for
hopefully we'll find out in season 7 do
me a favor and tell me off theories
below alright you've had enough of me
but please think about using my code a
damaru when buying things in fortnight
it really helps me make more in depth
fortnight videos rather than too much
clickbait like the people I won't
mention anyway imagine from PlayStation
great it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]
Jamie